more Delta passengers are stranded this
morning after a massive computer outage
the failure forced the airline to issue
a ground stop last night for domestic
flights crisscrossing the country planes
in the air were not affected dozens of
flights have already been canceled today
around 170 were canceled yesterday Kris
Van Cleave is at Reagan National Airport
outside Washington with Delta's response
Chris good morning good morning the
computers came back on and that ground
stop was lifted around midnight but the
airline is warning this issue that
involved its reservation system is going
to cause residual headaches for fliers
this morning as about a hundred flights
have been canceled for today now this
outage strongly impacted several of the
airline's major hubs grounding hundreds
of flights during the more than five
hour long outage New York's JFK Airport
reported Delta partner air france-klm
and Virgin Atlantic also experienced
some related delays this is the second
time in the last six months Delta has
been affected by a computer breakdown in
August a power failure at its operation
center caused more than 2,000 flights to
be canceled over three days in a
statement the airline CEO apologized to
fliers saying the disruption is not
acceptable to the Delta family who
prides itself on reliability and
customer service Delta has issued a
travel waiver for people who were flying
yesterday or today and now to put this
in perspective in the month of November
which is the last month we have
government stats Delta canceled no
flights for the entire month in the last
24 hours nearly 300 have been canceled
because of this outage so far Nora
alright Chris thank you